where you learn more about the latest
climate report by going right to the
source
well Richard ku Bosch is a meteorologist
at Berlin's free University and a
co-author of the report
professor kuba you've been with us
before but we thank you for joining us
here on tomorrow today all right let's
begin by talking about the report what
is the new or most significant in it
well I mean if you look at the report on
a whole its we have much more data and
so it's really now well stated that man
is responsible for the latest climate
change all right and in fact efforts to
cut carbon emissions haven't really been
working the emissions have been
increasing why is that well I mean the
report which was issued last week was in
stating how can one limit carbon
emissions and what it also points out
the roles of the different actors so you
have governments you have interest
groups yes or normal population and they
all have different interests and to sort
that out it's pretty difficult all right
well you mentioned governments why
doesn't the report outline concrete
steps that government should take well
one condition for this report was that
it should be policy prescriptive but
it's also we want to show pathways
possible options and then to let the
governments negotiate the right sing
resident today there's only one way and
you should follow that a there is no not
only a single solution one has to find a
really an optimal solution for all
countries in the world many governments
are focusing on renewable energies but
critics say that renewable energies are
too expensive what do you say to that
well I mean this report really calculate
how expensive are what options so how
expensive is it to go to renewables how
expensive is it to save energy or
expensive is to this carbon capture
storage so you take the carbon put it in
tools of 0's and if I not if you do all
these options the
it's not that expensive they talk about
percentage of the gross national product
or sole world all right now governments
are promising to limit limit global
average temperatures by two degrees is
that even possible well it's a tough
goal it's starting from pre-industrial
so what has been there in 1850 two
degrees so we have maybe half a degree
left but the idea is really to to to set
this goal that's not people go away say
we don't care and then at the end of the
day we would have eight degrees and
that's what we're really hard on
everybody what can we do as individuals
to limit our carbon footprint well I
mean they are these direct options
saying or cut down on your mission which
means use your energy more efficiently
or save energy
use renewable energies or put some
pressure on your government to go for
renewable XL and briefly what is your
personal outlook about where the planet
is heading well it's definitely we will
be getting warmer I'm not sure if it
will stick to this two degrees it might
be to allow for three degrees but I
think at the end of the day are we will
have to limit it and we will limit it
okay professor kibosh well it's been
very interesting talking to you thank
you very much for joining us